j'ai président prolongée zidane
djorkaeff sur les nouvelles idoles et
puis un kart 7
cette france un peu plus rien alors est
ce que c'est un coup de pouce à
l'intégration est un coup de foudre ci
soit votre identification savez la
france historiquement à une origine plus
rien
nous revendiquons permanence aux
origines judéo-chrétienne latine
non le fait que nous descendons des
baulois ce qui n'a rien à voir et nous
avons pays dont le nom la france est
emprunté à d'autres tribus les francky
était pas différent il ya donc un
ensemble partagé qui fait peut-être que
la france a été le pays qui a le mieux
ressenti compris la nécessité de
l'intégration et aujourd'hui c'est vrai
cette équipe à la fois tricolore et
multicolore et donne une belle image de
la france dans ce qu'elle a dû manistes
ans que l'anneau fort ce qu'est la drass
en deux heures et ce matin je regardais
le naturel dans le défilé depuis modifié
et
je voyais aussi qu'on ne souligne pas
assez que l'armée française qui a été
ovationné sur les champs elysées elle
est également à la fois multicolores et
ricol tout cela donne une belle image de
la france